hello everyone our very warm good
morning good afternoon or good evening
in whichever part of the world you are i
would like to welcome you all to the
very first session of chem informatics
for biomedical drug discovery program
this program is designed to address the
challenges which are associated with
understanding modeling screening and
applying chemi informatics strategies to
improve drug discovery results the
process of finding a new drug against a
chosen target for a particular disease
usually involves high throughput
screening wherein large libraries of
chemicals are tested for their ability
to modify the target
with contributions from leading
researchers in academia and
biotechnology pharmaceutical industry as
well as experts from the software
industry this comprehensive mental
guided training program explains how kim
informatics enhances drug discovery
today we'll discuss about some of the
topics which are mentioned here which
includes the molecular structure of
biological macromolecules history and
techniques amino acid structure and
function protein structures primary
secondary tertiary coronary structure
structural domain structural motif
protein subunit we'll also talk about
protein protein interactions
conformational analysis protein folding
sequence structure
and function relationship and we'll have
a hands-on session with biomolecular
visualization and finally an assignment
for you all to work on
so before we begin with today's session
as this is our first session i would
like to introduce us for those who have
joined us for the very first time
we are a us-based bioinformatics company
and we are working with multiple
academic and commercial collaborators to
develop easy-to-use analytical tools and
our mission is to make bioinformatics
more accessible
the omixlogic training has been
completed by over 24 000 participants
from 187 countries in over 300 workshops
in six different specialization tracks
which includes oncology infectious
diseases precision medicine neuroscience
data science for biomedical data and
chemi informatics for biomedic for bioma
for biomedical job discovery
and due to this fast growth our team is
working with local and regional
coordinators that are helping refine the
local program logistics and leverage our
online training resources adapting them
to the needs of students and researchers
around the world
over the past several years we have had
the privilege of working with a number
of organizations developing a training
program for research oriented students
faculty and democratizing bioinformatics
making this discipline accessible to
thousands of students and faculty around
the world
the omixlogic research-based training
programs are a result of close
collaboration between pine biotech and
numerous academic institutions that have
participated in content evaluation
curriculum review and project design
now getting back to the program
let's discuss how do omixologic
resources help in advancing
bioinformatics
so the omics logic is a portal for
practical and theoretical learning of
bioinformatics which includes various
omnic fields that we are covering data
science and structural biology i'll be
taking you through the portal and the
resources and what all you can
leverage from in just a while but before
that i would like to go through some of
the resources that you will have the
access to as a part of this program so
the omislogic portal is composed of
courses that are designed to take you
through the theoretical knowledge the
omics logic takes a combination of
training modules that i just explained
data analysis tools curated project data
sets and interactive sessions with
mentors will be conducted to give you a
clear path of the boom's taxonomy
pyramid and no matter what the user's
initial experience with bio
bioinformatics is omix logic is a useful
tool for gaining a baseline knowledge of
the theory behind bioinformatics
analysis of large data sets an
introduction to basic languages
basic coding languages like r and python
will also be given and beginning that
would help you begin a data analysis
project
we will also combine pre-recorded mental
sessions online live qmanage sessions
and self-kind and study material
including courses on the omixlogic learn
portal and example projects which will
include some practical assignments and
quizzes as well for an immersive
experience that has to be that has
proven to be effective in our well-known
and respected omis logic programs
so the program will leverage our
top-rated online tutorials that i'll be
just taking you through using the portal
with smart tracking of activity and
curated data sets designed for a great
learning experience
communication plays a key role for your
activities in the program so please make
sure that all the participants of the
program have joined the skype group
where you can access the session
recordings learn about the associated
resources to be completed as a part of
the session
get updated on supplementary material
and assignments you can also clarify
your questions or request a live q a
meet with the mentor for the same and
not only this but you will also get to
interact with our bioinformatics
community and grow your network
and we have a note for the participants
who have taken up the advanced
subscription level
as a part of the advanced subscription
level you are supposed to work on a
research project as soon as the program
training is over
so you are requested to fill out the
research proposal form
as soon as you have your research
question designed for the same
now what is there in the research
proposal for that is what i wanted to
highlight on so first of all you have to
mention your basic details and then you
have to mention the project title that
you would like to work on that you will
definitely come up with after removing
literature for the same
then you have to provide a project
description
and then a project summary that should
include the background of the literature
review that you went through what your
research question is specifically
what are the objectives and how you want
to answer the research question like a
flow that you have analyzed after you do
the literature and then you have to
provide the link for raw data now what
is the link of the raw data here it is
definitely the protein structure that
you want to work with so you have to
give the link uh to that particular
protein structure or molecule and then
you give the references we will share
this project proposal form with you over
an email as well i just wanted to go
through this proposal form with you once
so that you know what you're expected to
submit as soon as your training is
complete
all right so that were few points that i
wanted to discuss before we get started
with the session now let's quickly sign
up on the portal and make sure that we
have everything ready before we start
with the session and we have all things
done for the program
i'll quickly
share my google screen now
all right so those who have already
created an account for themselves on the
onyx logic law and portal please put a
yes or one in the chat box so that we
know you are all set and those who have
not created an account yet please do so
we'll be giving you a few minutes here
so that you can create an account our
team is here and if you face any
technical issues we'll be able to assist
you
we'll pause here for a minute or two so
that you can uh
easily create your account and the ones
who have created the account please take
this time to update your program
i'll give a quick
demo
uh about how you can sign up on the onyx
logic learn portal if you are new to
this platform so the link is in the chat
box just click on the link it will
redirect you to the honestly portal
you simply click on the login button
which will give you some options uh to
sign in either you create some
credentials for yourself and put in your
details which includes your name your
college or institute and create an
account that ways or you simply use any
one of your social media accounts that
could be google facebook
later and sign up
that is create an account on the portal
i'll use one of my google accounts to do
so
please feel free to ask us any question
related to sign up for now if you are
trying to sign up and not able to do so
be awaiting the responses in the chat so
that i know that we are all set to
proceed ahead
what about others have you set up your
profile
all right let me just also give a quick
demo for those who have created that
account yet
so what's the next step for them the
next step for them is to update their
profile
please make sure that you have an
updated profile picture your name should
be in title case and add a brief bio
about yourself that could include your
educational background or your research
and trust
an updated profile helps the mentor know
about your background first of all and
also we'll be monitoring monitoring your
progress and the back end for the
program on your profile section itself
so this is the place where we get to
know what you have been completing which
resources are you working on which
assignments have you submitted which
quizzes have you completed and also a
complete profile helps the recruiters
see your profiles and
maybe give you good nice offers so this
is what a complete profile could offer
you where you can see your activity you
can see your completed courses and also
once a course is completed you can
easily download your certificate and
share your achievements with the world
this is one thing that i wanted to share
that was about sign up and making sure
that you have a complete profile
the next thing is that each and every
uh step that you complete in your
coursework or in assignment that you
complete or quiz that you complete your
achievements will be recorded on our
achievement board and we'll be able to
monitor your progress from here
and achieving the specific points that
are required for you to complete a good
number of courses and your program could
give a chance to you to appear on our
leaderboard so here is the leaderboard
link all these links would be
found in the important links section
that is towards the bottom of the portal
so here you can uh get a chance to
appear on a leaderboard as well with an
exceptionally great performance on the
on this logic learn portal and also you
will stand the chance here to view the
job listings that we are updating on our
portal that you can view based on your
skill sets and you will find the list
the link to the job listings as well
to uh
the job listings on the portal itself
towards the end
these other links where it does not
mention
so that was all that i wanted to mention
now let's get started without any delay
and towards the end i'll be taking you
through the program page i'll be
discussing the schedule of this uh the
program including each and every session
and what we'll be covering and also in
showcase you the program page where you
will find all the recordings if you
happen to miss any one of them and where
you can also find the material with the
associated resources and the
supplementary material that you are
supposed to go through along with each
session
so that i'll be taking up towards the
end and now i would like to pass on this
session to dr mohit